what led up to this prayer video you and
Andrew Tate you're in a Masjid you
brought them into a mosque and you guys
are side by side Frank what people don't
know is me and Andrew go back maybe 15
years it's a kind of long story short
we're in Dubai and we were discussing we
were sitting actually with Steven Seagal
a few nights before I said you know what
I'm gonna take you we need to go
monsters one day because I want you to
feel how that connection is between the
Creator and the creation I can't explain
I said just when you go on a mushroom
quietly and you put your forehead to the
floor it's just something special he
said bro I would love to do it so two
three days later there was a UFC that
night we were going to go to the event
then we didn't last minute we just
thought you know what let's watch it a
local fast food restaurant in Dubai I
said okay let's go he messaged me uh
where are you I'll pick you up so you
know what I'll drive and we'll meet
there I've completely forgot at this
point about the mushroom he said uh I
said okay you pick me up and I will go
together and it's just after this shot
so they're kind of quiet then again I
thought you know what let's film this I
said you know what those people will say
yes it doesn't matter I said I'm gonna
film it because I just think let's put
this up there to show it will influence
young Muslim people for you